[موسيقى] [موسيقى] انعكاس آخر لهذه الظروف العالمية غير المسبوقة يكمن في العمل الذي قمنا به لتعديل مبادئنا التشغيلية مع الأحداث الجارية ، نعتقد اعتقادًا راسخًا أننا سنشهد تطورات هائلة في التدخلات الوقائية والعلاجات الطبية في الأشهر المقبلة بعد كل شيء انظر إلى أي مدى وصلنا إليه في الأشهر القليلة التي انقضت منذ أن أصبح كوفيد جائحة عالميًا لأول مرة في تاريخ إكسبو إكسبو العالمى. فرصة فريدة لعكس دراسة وتقييم تطور الوضع لرسم خريطة لجميع السيناريوهات المختلفة الممكنة وتحديد التدابير والأدوات الأكثر ملاءمة لضمان تجربة ممتعة وآمنة لجميع ابتكارات جودة السلامة وتجربة الزائر يجب أن تكون في صميم خططنا للمعرض سوف ندرس بمساعدة خبراء عالميين الشروط التي يجب الوفاء بها  من أجل زيارة آمنة
للموقع
والأجنحة وتكييف خطط تجربة الزائر لدينا
لتقديم خبير لا يصدق
في ضوء التأجيل الذي
طلبت منا أيضًا مراجعة الرسوم الحالية
بما في ذلك رسوم توصيل المرافق
التي نسقناها مع
كهرباء ومياه دبي
سلطة ضمان حد أقصى لرسوم توصيل الكهرباء لمدة 15 شهرًا ،
نأمل أن يساعدك ذلك في
خفض التكاليف وزيادة دعم
تواجدك في الموقع ، وهذا هو الأحدث
في سلسلة من التنازلات والاسترخاء
التي قدمناها من أجل
تقليل التكاليف
من  باقات الاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية الخاصة بنا مع
شريك في
صلاة إلى عمليات التفتيش على السلطة إلى التكاليف
المتعلقة بتصاريح الأحداث ،
نحن نذهب إلى أبعد من
ذلك
لأننا نعلم أنك قد ذهبت
إلى أبعد الحدود وكذلك
[موسيقى]
لك